my hope is that here in the final  ticking of the clock of history we are  going to end our prodigal descent into  the desert world of the ego and return  with what we have learned the fruits of  the prodigal journeying of the erring  son which is what this tree has been  returned with the fruits of that  prodigal wandering to the larger  hillmanfamily  that waits on us in the rain forests in  the deserts in the marshes in the thorn  forests of this planet the archaic  people are waiting for us to get on the  train and then the train will be able to  depart but we have to awaken to our past  and then we can set a course toward a  meaningful future  [Music]